- Last time that Kym
Whitley was here though
she shared this moment.
- My girl, my girl.
- I was like, she better be your girl.
Let's see this video.
(Laughing)
- It was at an awards show
called the Neighborhood Awards
and Steve Harvey was giving
it and I was on the stage
and I thought I was gonna
be funny and say something
to Shemar Moore, flirting,
because you know my mouth.
So he comes up and he looks at
me and I was like, Oh my God.
And I whispered in his ear
and he came up close and
I said, don't pick me up,
please don't pick me up.
He was like, I'm not going pick you up.
And he grabs my face
and he sticks his tongue
- What?!
- Down my throat.
- [Kelly] Ew!
(Audience groaning)
[Kym] And I don't even
know if my body can - Yes!
Look at that right there.
(Audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I mean, is this
how you remember the moment?
Cause see how I see it is
she was trying to be all big
and bold and you were
like, Oh, okay, checkmate.
- I was gonna say, I was
gonna say she just gave you
the Kym Whitley PG, her version.
Okay, okay, she started all that.
I was minding my own business.
I was sitting down in the front row.
I was just chilling, enjoying the show.
They asked me to come and
hang out and enjoy the party.
Steve Harvey was in the
house telling his jokes
I'm sitting there and she
comes up, she gets introduced
to do a category and
starts running her mouth.
She goes, Oh, what's up Shemar?
What's up light skin?
And she's like, I don't
even like light skin
but that's Shemar Moore!
So she just kept running her mouth
And then in my brain, I
was like, You know what?
Just go for it.
Just call her out.
And so I just got up for
no reason, impromptu.
I walked up on stage
And then she kind of trotted over to me
and in my brain I was like, Oh we're about
to give 'em a show right now.
And she had no idea.
And I just was on one.
I think I had a little sip of something
before I went into the show.
- Some liquid courage.
- And so I was like, all
right, let's do this.
And so she came over and
she was looking at me like
You ain't gonna do nothing.
And I was like, Oh yeah?
And so I grabbed her whole
face and just did the thing.
And then she buckled, she
buckled and I was like
Girl, don't make me drop you.
Don't make me drop you, cause
that's gonna be all bad.
(Audience laughing)
- I love though that
she's so on all the time.
I love her, she's a regular guest here
and I love her so much, she's so quick
and I love that you
caught her off her game.
She was just like, wait, wait, what?
- Yeah, yeah, no, it was,
I mean, it was a big risk
on my part because you
don't mess with comics.
You don't mess with
- [Kelly] The timing or?
- Yeah, the timing, you don't
mess with that so I didn't
- Unless you're Shemar
Moore and you're coming up
to give a kiss.
- But if you notice, I
didn't have anything to say.
I didn't need to say anything,
I just need to be about it.
Get it done.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's a
man right there, okay!
- I stuck and I got out.
- Oh my God, it was amazing.
I just loved even her telling this story.
She was getting all red.
She was funny.
It was funny.
I just love anytime you can
get a comic off their game.
It's like, that's hard to do.
- That's honestly, I've
been doing this 28 years
and that's honestly you, one
of the most memorable moments
of Hollywood, just because -
- Fun.
It was so impromptu, outta nowhere.
I mean nobody will ever forget that.
- [Kelly] Oh My God,
especially her. (laughs)
It is funny what they hold
onto, but Sonic is CGI.
So you've done a little
CGI work I heard on
was it Criminal Minds?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] So, wait, tell
everybody cause this is amazing.
- [Shemar] Okay.
- [Kelly] Are you allowed,
cause for continuity,
do they like you to, cause
I haven't been able to
change hair before or do certain things.
Were you supposed to -
did you get in trouble?
- That right there is one I
would really like to forget
and nobody will let me forget it.
What happened is my character,
this is on Criminal Minds
and my character - is
the Hondo beard for SWAT
but on Criminal Minds I had kind of
a perfectly manicured goatee.
And so I had come to work thinking
that the day before was the
last day of the episode.
So I shaved down my goatee
to almost nothing and it didn't match.
So I got to rehearsal and I said
Hey guys, I just gotta let
you know this doesn't match
what I was doing, what
I was rocking yesterday.
And so then they ran with it
and they were like, Okay, well
you know what, we're
gonna deal with it in CGI
but we're gonna have to
put green dots on you
cause then we can put the
goatee back on in post.
And I'm such a dumb-ass
(Kelly laughs)
because I had heard stories.
One of the crew members had worked
on a Tom Hanks movie and they said
Yeah Tom Hanks had that beard,
but they had to do it for him
when he would cut it too much
which was a complete lie.
So they said that they had to put
green tape on Tom Hanks' chin.
So I'm like, well, Tom Hanks is
an Oscar winner, like, he's Tom Hanks.
So if Tom Hanks has to do
it, then I gotta do it.
So they put the dots on
and then my character
is in a serious scene
and I'm doing the scene.
And then they came back
to me in after each take
and they said, You know what?
We're gonna have to put a little bit more
just so it's easier for us in post.
So by the end of the gag I had
this whole green tape goatee.
I could barely move my face.
- [Kelly] You are such a team player.
- But I was dead serious
with a green tape goatee
and it took about the fifth
take to where my leading lady
who, baby girl, Kirsten Vangsness
she just couldn't hold it.